[Music]
one month ago today a tornado ripped
through mayfield kentucky and devastated
the community there cleanup efforts are
still underway after a tornado that
wiped out neighborhoods destroyed iconic
sites and claimed the lives of nearly 80
people in the state of kentucky alone
novelist and pulitzer prize finalist
bobby ann mason grew up in mayfield and
in a special essay for cbs morning she
reflects on the catastrophe that forever
changed the place that she calls home
i grew up right here
on this farm in mayfield kentucky when i
was a kid i sat under the big trees and
read nancy drew mysteries
after college i moved away but i
returned often to see my parents who
stayed here in the house where i was
born
mayfield was a traditional little
southern town with a neat courthouse but
that's history
[Music]
just after thanksgiving
mayfield had a christmas parade around
the square
a celebration
unprecedented in its joy and civic pride
it's difficult to fathom how much pain
there is too among many of these
families
then
the tornado that roared through kentucky
a month ago
wrecked the center of town and toppled
the steeple of that courthouse and
demolished most of the buildings around
it it was merciless unrelenting and
indiscriminate in its power it was
shocking
most famously the tornado flattened the
candle factory
i closed my eyes and all i see is people
hollering and screaming for help
the devastation is worse than i imagined
when i saw it on tv
everything was just falling on top of us
i was under there somewhere
i'd never seen destruction bigger than
one house but this is blocks and blocks
and it goes from miles into the country
whole neighborhoods lost their homes and
jobs people were thrust out into the
unknown at christmas
some could go to relatives but many were
scattered at hotels and state park
lodges
the tornado was an enormous trauma
mayfield will be feeling the effects for
generations
i grieve for the people here
many blocks are small
modest houses
rentals are scarce and i don't know what
these residents will do
the large downtown churches were gutted
but they've made do in temporary homes
a big christmas tree rose triumphantly
in front of the wrecked courthouse
so there's hope
western kentuckians are resilient that's
no surprise
given the farm heritage of this region
[Music]
sometimes a crop fails
or a tornado blows your house away
nature can be cruel mayfield got a
terrible thrashing but people here are
strong
and they are busy making plans and
talking about what they want their town
to become
houses are already going up
mayfield faces so many questions
can we restore the courthouse
should we try to recreate the past or
think boldly about the future
challenges like technology politics and
climate
swirl around the whole world these days
with all this confusion how can we make
good choices
i hope we think hard
about what sort of new town we want to
make the tornado reminded us that
nothing is
permanent nothing is secure but starting
over from scratch is a great opportunity
to do something just brilliant
and speaking of brilliant that's
a novelist from mayfield in front of her
childhood home which was also destroyed
in that tornado uh a reminder that
people will bounce back and they're
asking themselves what kind of town do
we want to be now yeah talk about
putting a positive positive spin if you
can put a positive spin on that give us
an opportunity to do something brilliant
i love that i love that we have to
remember from the outside looking in
there's no expiration date on pain and
devastation that's right so they still
need help said it best nature can be
very cruel